I am so happy to be here
my name is Ron I'm originally from the
south side of Chicago Illinois
the correct response is a woop woop I
will not accept a belated woop woop it
just deserves one because Chicago is an
extremely rough place to grow up in
especially if you're the only brother on
the block that's in the bump and Alanis
Morisette so you ought to know I moved
to origin I love it it reminds me of
Chicago with subtle differences like in
Chicago was always oh snap it's a gang
member
oh snap it's a crackhead and noir again
it's been oh snap the blackberries are
in season
this is a delicious situation are there
I left Chicago because there's a lot of
gangs and violence I did not know the
northwest also had gangs they are not
scary are effective but they try so hard
I even ran into a gang on the Oregon
coast of all places and I don't like to
be racist but it was a gang of
blackbirds a real murderers room and I
dealt with them just like the gangs in
Chicago I just puffed my chest out
knuckled up and said you brothers ain't
getting these cranberry muffins
[Applause]
and then I ran away I'm still very happy
that I left Chicago I know if I never
left I wouldn't have tried some things I
now love and enjoy like iced coffees or
white women I'm just kidding
coffee is gross every time I drink some
I get really sick which leads me to
believe I may be allergic to energy
[Laughter]
which I later found out is not something
you can put on a medical marijuana
application
but there's always someone that tries to
make you feel bad about what you enjoy I
call these people my parents-in-law we
have a weird relationship I kind of
treat them like a Walmart which I'll
explain it means I really don't like
going to them for anything I prefer it
if they stay out of my town but I get a
strange satisfaction from stealing from
them
[Applause]
mostly because they believe I need a
real job and they are so difficult if
you ever get an interview they always
want to know so much about you like the
soundtrack of your life or what type of
tree you would be and I'm a bonsai but
that's my damn business and if you get
past that there's a drug test that's
never fair one time they tried to give
me a mouth swab drug test which is where
they take a piece of cotton run the
inside of your cheek to get your DNA and
that's how they find out what you like
to do that's against everything I
believe in there's no way I'm gonna let
you take something that you made my
people pick two hundred years ago and
then turn around to use it to deny me a
job
if I knew that's how you treated your
employees I would have never have taken
the time to duct-tape these Cheetos back
full of urine to my legs that was a
waste of mine and my son's day thank you
guys so much
fantastic
one punches
[Applause]
you